[Musique]
silicone des films western une plante
qui fréquente les bons comme les
méchants
[Musique]
boule du désert c'est son surnom
il y a 150 ans des immigrants russes
auraient transportés par mégarde c'est
semences mélangé à des graines de lin
la plante a depuis envahi bien plus que
les esprits
enracinant Dakota du Sud en 1873 et la
désormais colonisé la majorité des
États-Unis
y compris certaines zones dans l'Ouest
canadien
elle a compris depuis longtemps que
roulait lui préfère du chemin
c'est sa façon à elle de faire voyager
ses semences
sa terre d'accueil elle l'a trouvé dans
les zones arrêt doux dépourvue de
végétation
quelque part elle a le génie de pousser
en boule
à maturité la plante se sépare de sa
racine elle se larve d'elle-même et
comme ballon elle se met à rouler au
hasard du vent qu'il a
les semences qui couvrent ses branches
se détache alors au fur et à mesure
entre 100 et 200 000 par buisson
une fois dans le sol les semences
attendent patiemment les conditions
propices pour pousser avant de se
remettre à virevolter dans le vin d'où
le nom qu'on lui donne en français le
virevolta
au-delà des films elle a aussi fait la
manchette parfois en bloquant des routes
en envahissant des cultures ou en
couvrant des quartiers résidentiels
comment Californie en 2018
c'est dans cet état qu'on a aussi
découvert un nouvel hybride de la plante
une variété australienne et russe le
nouvel hybride produit deux fois plus de
végétation et de semences
en quelques années il a déjà conquis une
partie de la Californie
dans les Prairies canadiennes c'est une
plante de la même famille qui s'invite
aussi un peu partout dans les champs le
kushia à balai
comme sa cousine le coca disperse ses
semences en roulant
un cauchemar pour les agriculteurs car
il est difficilement à s'en débarrasser
le cocher à balai a de plus acquis une
résistance au glyphosate un puissant
herbicide
[Musique]
loin de perdre en vigueur ces buissants
roulant pourraient même tirer profit des
saisons sèches dans l'ouest du continent
nord-américain
il pourrait gagner encore un peu de
terrain sur les autres plantes qui
oseraient se dresser sur leur route
[Musique]